à partir de demain lundi la comédie
française présentera l'école des femmes
dans une nouvelle mise en scène de jean
paul roussillon
décors et costumes de jacques le marquer
c'est une cocréation c'est à dire que
deux acteurs on préparait simultanément
le même rôle et le tiendrons
alternativement ainsi arnold sera-t-il
interprété par pierre dux et michal où
mme agnès sera isabelle adjani 17 ans
comptez moi cette histoire
les fortes étonnante difficile a à g t
sur le balcon a travaillé au frais
lorsque jeudi passé sous les arbres
doperait est jeune on ya fait qu'ils
rencontrent en ma vue du nem leur
révérence aussitôt le salut moi pour ne
pas manquer à la civilité je fis la
révérence aussi de mon côté soudain il
me refais une autre révérence
ouais je refais de même une autre en
diligence et lui d'une troisième
aussitôt repartant d'une troisième aussi
géré par à l'instinct quand on demander
à guitry quoi d'neuf vue répondait
toujours molière si vous voulez pour moi
il n'ya pas il n'ya pas mettre au goût
du jour parce que je suis très amoureux
s'étaient et j'ai toujours pensé qu' il
y avait il ya toute possibilité pour que
les gens trouvent un certain modernisme
quand même dans cette pièce
je crois que c'est peut-être des
productions ou des choses qui ont fait
que souvent on en joue que la forme
alors ça peut peut-être risqué de se
démoder je dis ça tout à fait doucement
mais je crois que dès le moment où on
commande en prendre le fond dès le
moment où on fait pas forcément
abstraction mais que c'est un auteur ou
à tout prix on doit rire si on commence
à en jouer un petit peu le dame qui est
dessous je crois que c'est une chose qui
est qui est très présente
je te les grilles faucher désespérée
contre elle n'est cependant jamais je ne
le vis si belle je me suis yeux nous
parut six paires sont jamais je ne
pourrai désirent s'y pressent je sens là
dedans il faudra que je crève
si de mon triste sort 10 grâce au chien
alors moi peut-être j'exagère
en prenant le grave mais je trouve qu'il
y a des gens qui exagèrent tellement en
empannant la forme qu'a jour où l'eau
qui vient à quelqu'un de très bien lui
qui prendra du fonds et qui regardera la
forme et qui fera le lien je crois que
maintenant il faut plus poussée au fond
tellement sous la forme par partout bien
entendu mais en général disons dans un
théâtre comme le français selon les gens
qui viennent savent ont déjà vu et tout
le monde de parole fait un monstre mais
dont nous tous on a des idées un petit
peu préconçues sur les choses on a les
shows des souvenirs qui nous ont marqués
congard qu'on veut vouloir retrouver
il n'y a pas la naïveté n'est pas
tellement admis qu'on puisse faire dès
le moment où ces faits à lecteurs en
aimant ces textes là il est pas
tellement admis qu'on puisse faire des
expériences sincère alors bien sûr dès
le départ ça peut choquer et puis
peut-être qu'un an ou deux ans après on
peut dire en bas oui il trouvait ça très
classique pour la première fois sur la
scène du tas de france et il y à une
tournette quels en sont les avantages
c'est un avantage pour moi ils n'ont pas
ce qu'il ya toujours la règle classique
d'unique
ça reste tout de même à lieu unique et
je pense que le système de la tournette
permet aux acteurs une pas voir des
entrées permettent beaucoup de
classicisme si vous voulez dans le jeu
mais derrière le il ya une image qui
changent et je pense que vis-à-vis de
notre siècle à nous du côté image ça
donne un attrait sans faire perdre à mon
avis le texte en donnant toute sa valeur
au texte